the title of this talk is the title of
this talk is more generators and I think
one of the very first talks I ever gave
at PI data at a PI data event was about
generators in fact the very first PI
data London that I ever attended in 2013
boy that's going back a long way I gave
a I didn't actually I didn't I gave a
keynote because the other guy cancelled
and so I had the whole audience to
myself and so let's see let's see what
we can do now five years on with
generators generators have been around
in Python for 15 years or so interesting
question that I keep coming to is how
come you see people talk about them at
conferences and everyone thinks they're
such a cool feature but nobody really
uses them like you don't see any big
libraries use them as a core metaphor or
core API other than some of the async
stuff how come it doesn't show up that
much in the field of data science now
one huge disclaimer despite having
spoken for now my fifth year in a row at
a PI data London and having spoken at 25
pi data's in the world I don't really
know a whole lot about data science or
machine learning I do mostly scientific
computing I'm more of a programmer that
I have anything else so please if you
want no one a lot about programming just
just leave the room I won't be too upset
ok so let's get started my name is James
Powell you know this is the Python
community so I really should make sure
to include my Twitter handle or I should
put my email here so I'm James at don't
use this code comm and my twitter handle
is also
don't use this coat okay so we'll make
sure that we print those out so we can
get started probably the most important
things now as you can see at the top of
my file here I have a couple of simple
vim macros just to make my life easier
so as we go through this I'll be
pressing one of those key combos and
you'll see some output at the bottom of
the screen and so let's see if we can
use that to kind of follow along now one
unfortunate thing here is because these
aren't slides I can't do the
self-promotional thing of getting all of
you to follow me on Twitter by having
like a big Twitter thing at the bottom
of the screen but because this is Python
you know we can just override print to
always print my Twitter handle every
time I print something out so let's just
do that really quickly and we'll see
that if this gets annoying or not will
say from built-ins import print as
underscore prints so don't lose the
original print will print what we were
originally going to print and then we'll
print out oops
will print out follow me on twitter at
and then my Twitter handle
yeah this is gonna be the hole it's
gonna be able to 45 minutes folks get
ready you're ready for this and let's
just put this all the way on the side of
the screen there we go and let's give
this a try with this module and see if
it works well oh and by the way we need
to make these from built-in to import
print ads this is Python 3 that's one
small thing we have to make sure that
we're using Python 3 here so we'll just
there we go because unfortunately
sometimes oh there we go follow me on
Twitter although that's kind of annoying
so what we'll do is we'll just play with
this a little bit this is look this is
harder than it looks by the way this is
much harder than it looks folks I'm not
faking it this is for real if first and
first top else cuz we want this to be
really classy we'll only put the Twitter
handle
we'll only put the full follow me on
Twitter for the first time it prints out
there we go isn't that fantastic so
hopefully we won't do this for the whole
talk cuz that'll be really tedious but
that's kind of what you're in store for
if you want to leave now that's okay
let's give you a quick overview of what
we're gonna talk about in this session
it took us five minutes to even prints
out the title so let's see how fast we
can go so the first part we're gonna
talk about a little bit of review the
second part and so this part in the
second part we are going to talk about
what generators actually are in the
third part we're going to talk about
why they are not what you think they are
and in the last part we're gonna have
some fun okay
now let's get started with what
generators were the arms so we'll just
create a new file called review dot P Y
will grab these from the top and do you
want to grab the print and really
actually have us print out my Twitter
handle every slide or every print ok
code neither did I that's just I'm
really cheap
okay so let's figure out what it
generator you really do want me to do
that every time okay
otherwise otherwise you might think I'm
faking this whole thing okay so there we
go
so there's our custom print function
okay I'm gonna start off with a very
simple question and since this is so
tedious to see on the screen which is
hypnosis let's start off with a very
simple question for you
my question for you is what's the
difference between these two yeah we can
try that you can also sit closer to the
front the colors do Solarize like hey
look at that
thank you very much for your feedback
okay what's the difference between these
two that function okay come on folks
this is like the very beginning what's
the difference in these two okay
now if I make this a little bit simpler
and I ask you what's the difference
between these two from the perspective
of somebody just using them who can't
see the source code is there any
difference between these two from the
perspective of just using these two they
do the same thing right they're
basically formal differences and what
you could say as well somebody were
clever there might be some help text on
this and you wouldn't see that help text
on the add two because it's an anonymous
function right but you'd see the help
text on the ad and the name wouldn't be
right but then I'd say you know what
this is Python we can just monkey patch
this thing right and this name equals
add two and then it's really it really
becomes difficult for us to distinguish
between these two and in fact it turns
out that these are just two ways to
write essentially the same thing except
there are certain syntactical
restrictions to the lambda that we don't
have in a normal function we can't have
statements
it's just expressions let me throw in
another example and I want you to tell
me what the difference between this is
and we'll call this a door
and we'll put a pass here so we'll use
this in a second okay
how about this one what's the difference
between this structure and the previous
structures do you see any difference
still adds numbers it's just a different
formulation and you might say well we
still have the problem with the name of
the help text but trust me we can patch
that out now what an interesting thing
here is you might say well there is a
difference because if I have this adder
I can take this code and I can move it
somewhere I can't move the other code I
can do things with it that I can't do it
the other one right I can do something
like this and I can initialize this to
zero and when I actually run it I can
give it some kind of weird behavior
where it remembers some state because
this is an object and objects are about
State and so now the adding behind the
scenes transparently add something in
there but I'll tell you what are you
talking about that's nonsense
I knew the same thing with my original
add up here right and I really didn't do
much to change this and you might say ah
but James there's something more oops
let's do we've gotta make this global
and this should just be and you could
say you can actually even do more you
could say you know I don't really like
using Global's even though that's the
same and you know having this global
state it's not encapsulated and I'll say
oh it's not encapsulated is it well can
I do this
I just add it's a function right
functions in Python can have they have a
little ticked so you can see behavior is
the same and you might say ah but if you
were being really clever you could make
two versions of this and they operate
separately because it's a class classes
can create instances right and because
classes can create instances we can have
two of these and they both have
independent state right and I might say
yeah but but why can't I just do this
and then I don't even need this this
crazy thing here I just use non-local
and then we finally get tired of this
exercise and what we realize is that
what we have discovered here is a
fundamental principle of computer
science namely and I'll finish the
example before I tell you what the
principle is boy I must be I must be
very concentrated to be able to talk and
code at the same time huh who's
impressed I hope some of you impressed
this is really really hard this is
really hard ok so there we're there and
we're done so we can see exact same
thing and in one case we have a closure
and a function returning the [ __ ] to the
other case we have an object and we've
now discovered first hand by trying to
tease apart some differences a
fundamental proper instable in computer
science which is objects and closures
are identical there's a clear
equivalence between them let's park that
for a second and let's talk about
something slightly different here's all
we're going to talk about that slightly
different let's let's take let's pretend
that we have a function that computes
something and because I because this is
hard enough as it is I'll just give you
a dumb compute function that doesn't do
anything that interesting but it takes a
tenth of a second to run right so it
returns a random number between 1 and 10
and it takes a tenth of a second run
see you can even feel that you never
feel that tenth of a second there now I
can have a function just a regular old
function that maybe does a couple of
computations in a row so so maybe it
calls this function ten times
all right and I can print out what this
function does and we can see this in
actually should take about a second and
you can see it takes about a second now
I can look at this and I can say that's
very interesting it takes a full second
it computes everything upfront and I can
use what I learned up before to see if I
could just take this code here and put
it into my class formulation all right
there we go
and again if I do this you can see this
oh we have to of course put a mark up
here there we go and you can see they
both do the same thing now one thing
that I can notice is that typically when
I actually want to use this I'm just
going to iterate through the values
right I will put a mark up here just so
we can you know the last time I did one
of these presentations it went on
YouTube I got 300,000 views and then
some people in the comments were like
wow he's really good at using them and
then some guys like he's such a noob his
Vince Keeler's sock he doesn't even use
VIP for visually impaired graph and I'm
like okay we got to step up my game so
I'll try to step up my game here but you
can see you know this is the example we
really happened that YouTube comments
are harsh they're always very harsh but
you can see we have the same equivalents
now something interesting we can see
it's because we're iterating over this
one thing that we might know is that in
Python whatever we have a structure that
looks like the following we know that
behind the scenes Python turns it into
something that looks like the followed
and then there's a cat right here and
then you try and get the next value out
of the iterator the excise tense right
and an iterator for that and you accept
a stop iteration and break so we know
there's an equivalence here and we know
that if we if we implement it or and
next we could do something kind of
interesting so I'll show you what we can
do we can create our own object that's
iterable we'll say that it's it's own
iterator and in the next we'll just
return the next value well what we'll do
is in the iterator we'll just keep track
of the size of the computation we want
to do which is 10 and the next we'll
just say if not self dot size raise stop
iteration otherwise decrement self dot
size and just return this right and now
if we look at this and we no longer need
these here if we look at this we have
and we have to go back up to our mark to
run everything we can see does the same
thing so what we've discovered here is
that there's another concordance here
that we can swap out calling something
for iterating over something but if I
were to tell you and we can see that
this result is actually a lot better
because one thing that you notice from
the two variants if I give you these two
variants side by side there's one thing
that I want you to notice and this is
one of the keys that people first learn
when they learn about generators and see
if you can notice it ok did you notice
something let me put a break let me put
a little visual break between the two
instances of these two functions I want
you to tell me really quickly
anybody sees a difference between these
two formulations because all I've done
right now is you kind of played around
with sticking some code in a different
place anyone see something really
visually different there one's immediate
and the other one is streaming what we
discovered here is we've discovered some
laziness
now something kind of interesting occurs
when we think about generators and
Python because there is some distinct
advantages to the second form namely one
notice there's no storage we're just
doing one computation returning the
value here their storage notice number
two we're getting the values only as we
need them so if we only looked at one
value the top version takes all of one
second and the bottom version only takes
a tenth of a second see that first one
took the entire time it was eager to the
whole computation and gave us the whole
results we threw away 90% of it the
second one only gave us a results as we
wanted so we can say oh that's really
interesting that's a lot more efficient
for both a memory and a time perspective
we're customizing what we what resources
we use in terms of computational time
and memory - exactly what the user wants
and the whole nice thing about
generators is generators are this idea
that you can write a formulation the
above both out all of this tedium so we
can just write this here grab our code
from here
and we can see this generator
formulation here and this class
formulation here are just as equivalent
as this function formulation here in a
class and this raw formulation here so
we can see is that generators are a way
for us to very conveniently formally
describe a structure that performs a
computation on demand where internally
the structure itself looks very similar
to something that has an inner and a
next employee okay so that's our review
I hope that was well within what all of
you know because that's just the start
of where we're gonna be let's take a
look at has anyone lost okay good let's
let's take a look at next what large
errors
so one of the things that we saw from
that example and while I grab the top of
this file here and my print statement
which we didn't use because I wasn't
highlighting it each time but we'll use
it by the end and we'll just hide some
of this stuff because it's little
garbage on the screen like that this
what we saw is that we saw immediately
some laziness versus eagerness one of
them runs the completion one of them
does the entire computation the other
one eagerly gives you the computation as
you go and what we saw and what we might
also know is some kind of pipelining
mechanism so one of the things that we
see from that generator is the generator
only gives you values as you asked for
them so if we take our compute let's
just copy our compute over if we have
actually no how about this from review
import compute oh look at this this
really is now a Python package not just
a module and we I'm doing this off the
top of my head come on gotta give me
something
oh let me just do this
and let's call this okay there we go
because the other module has that at the
top and now everything's gonna have this
isn't that great let's do this pretty
cool that's that's gonna be so annoying
let's go be so annoying
okay so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do a little bit of we're gonna be
nice to you because that's just gonna
annoy you I'll just move this out here
top
okay there we go
so what we can see is we have now an
infinite sequence right so if I say for
X in F print X I now have an infant
sequence it should be very difficult to
mod or eagerly because you can't store
an infinite sequence anywhere and what
we know from this is we can do all sorts
of cute little pipelining things just
like at the shell things which
approximate the kind of data pipelining
that we often do on fancy platforms like
Hadoop and spark and whatnot and we know
that Python gives us the inner tools
modulator tools module gives a lot of
helpers so we can do things like take a
generator at Tia to make copies we can
enumerate that to get you know the index
of it and then we can do something like
slice each of these so we can offset
each of these by an amount and then what
we can do is we can zip them together to
put the star here make sure we have
enough closing parentheses we can zip
these together and this is a very useful
tool called n wise that gives us
pairwise views of some structure right
so I'll show this to you in action you
can see just using what's in Python we
can get like pairwise views we need a
BBC CD and we can even take this further
and we can do fun stuff like getting
windowed averages which is just the sum
of these values divided by the length of
these values for some values in a
windowed size of whatever we want and so
now we can take all of this fanciness
and we can do windowed averages of f of
some sighs let's do windowed averages of
size 3 and now we have a lot of little
helpers in a very terse almost
functional form you can see it's
processing an infinite sequence of
numbers and getting like the three
windowed averages right we do moving
averages and that's really cool but
there's more there's one other thing
that we might we might have noticed and
I want to ask you is anyone ever seen an
API that looked kind of like this
let's do this three times there was some
function that you had to run first there
was some function that you had to run
second and there was some function you
had to run last and you had to run them
in those orders otherwise it would be
you know total anarchy cats and marrying
dogs you know crossing the streams
absolutely absolute chaos
you had some API that's really order
dependent and it's so easy to screw up
because there's nothing enforcing that
order well one thing that we also know
about generators is that they are a
sequencing mechanism so we can't take
all the code that we wrote here you know
the average programmer writes 100 lines
of code a day and we're already at 200
so you're really getting your money's
worth folks we can do this right and fi
will be an instance of this generator
and we can do this and you can see we
get sequencing except we can't screw it
up and we might even know that in Python
3 6 and later we have this async/await
structure so we can even do stuff like
this you know create tasks that yield
and print some message out and we can
write our own scheduler and
right and we can just you know do
something like scheduler or tasks
hello task goodbye and we can see it and
we can see that the sequencing is
actually very important it's key to why
we have generators as the async
mechanism in Python for for single
processes asynchronous you can see that
what you have from the scheduling is the
yield is actually doing literally what
it says yielding control back to the
scheduler and the scheduler is figuring
out how to enter loose so this is why
generators work this way now let's talk
about something else let's talk about
why generators don't appear in data in
in pi data talks why I'm gonna has given
this and it's not just because I'm done
that's all I know
that is what answer this is really all I
know I wish I could give a talk on
machine learning I'm sure it would be
interesting maybe as interesting as the
average machine learning talk is which
is very I will I will that we're really
going off the rails here aren't we
I will say that one thing that we don't
see a PI data conference is we don't see
in the world is you know out there
there's probably like a million
biologists whose state of the art tool
that using its pearl and so a tool like
generators is a step Python itself is a
step beyond what they're doing and
Python with generators they're doing a
lot of text processing on like DNA
sequences and looking for substring
matches and maybe this is an appropriate
technique for them but we don't see this
in the world of scientific computing or
numerical analysis and I'll give you an
idea why that is one problem is that
fundamentally even though there's a very
nice lazy mechanism Python is pretty
pretty junk at doing anything numeric
computing related so I'll show you a
very simple example let's just do let's
just time to operations
well time using this generator and this
window to average mechanism against and
I'll get I'll get this code from up here
because I don't really want to cut and
paste
they want to import that well time this
against just doing an operation on like
a numpy India Ray random import random
and we'll just create a random number
and D array with the values from 0 to 10
of size a million ok and what we'll do
is we'll just do very similar to have
that n wise up there works we'll just do
something like this to get the window to
view so we'll just divide by two and
we'll see how long this takes you make
sure that we have nothing missing in
this time it and only run this five
times because it's not gonna be that
fast ok you can see it took like point
one seconds here and we'll try the same
thing with our generator approach and
we'll see what happens and it's not
gonna be it's not gonna be very good
it's just that Python integers and
Python lists or even Python generators
are just not a very good tool for any
sort of numerical computation you can
see why as a tool these don't really
show up when you're doing large you know
stream multiplications or you know
vector operations will just take take
this from here take that from there we
don't need you don't need this stewey
and we'll just say from random
import ran range XS equals R and rating
from zero to ten for this range this is
like an interview this is like the heart
this is the hardest interview that means
the least I've ever done and will do
this list windowed I hope if I ever
interview at any of your companies you
ask me exactly the questions that we're
covering in this presentation but we'll
see how fast this is and we probably
need to make sure we type this right
they ever seen anyone live code this
much code and get it right I've never
I've never done this before this is
really special
you can see the speed of these two
things boy this is slow and windowed
average let's try that one more time
let's see it's really really really slow
even the construction of the inci it's
the two seconds versus 0.09 sentence for
a million integers right so you can see
even at very large scales if I make this
a billion yeah we have we have easy
memory use but if you want to do
anything numeric involving large streams
just use an umpire and the array its
cache coherent it's packed into memory
it's just gonna be faster this generator
approach and using lists and Python
integers for anything that's
mathematical nature it doesn't work so I
think this is one of the reasons why we
don't see generators being used as part
of data science libraries in this kind
of numerical stream processing sense
because for if you're doing text
processing you're a biologist and you're
comp the computational part of your
computational biology isn't really that
computational yeah it's a great tool if
you're doing serious machine learning or
models or deep learning it's not
actually a very valuable tool because
it's hindered by the poor mathematical
support in Python itself python is an
orchestration language of glue language
and a mechanism like generators is not
going to give you the ability to do that
much but let's look at the last part of
our presentation we have 15 minutes
let's have some fun because if we really
think about it when we go back to what
we learn about generators in this second
section and we think about this
sequencing what we can see is that
generators are a mechanism that can fit
into orchestration they can allow us to
do to give us structured
program that the program might not
already have they're not necessarily a
computational mechanism they're not
about you know doing very quick vector
operations because numpy can do that way
better and if it's out of memory you
have other tools that can do out of
memory you know Julia can do out of
memory operations that's part of the
core language what you might think
though is generators might be a tool for
structure of their program and what's a
common non mathematical structure for a
program what about a graph right we've
seen this these used to be all the rage
like a year or two ago I don't know why
they're not that popular anymore
but the idea that you can take some
equation and do it as a graph and if
each of the nodes are very hard to
compute you can minimalistic ly
recompute the nodes to get some results
so think about some operation where your
will do this very simply will do
something like this do I really have ten
minutes because I'm gonna need ten I
don't need ten minutes to finish this
okay what we're gonna do is we're going
to build in the next ten minutes a graph
computation framework at about 70 lines
of Python using generators so what we
might have is you might have some term
and the term is just a generator that
yields its own value and yep a new value
and this is going to be really really
sloppy so we can always improve this
slightly we'll do something like this
okay
so this is just a generator that can
take new values it's just a little
computational unit we're going to fit it
into a larger structure and maybe we'll
do simple simple addition of terms okay
and this again will be something where
we set the value to none and what we'll
do is we'll do like a while true and
we'll say value equals sum of next e for
in terms okay and you can see we can do
ad term one term to term three and by
virtue of these being you know live
computational units we can say for X and
Q critics or actually we'll do it like
this while true print next thank you
okay now every time we do this we do a
loop but let's do and we have to yield
the value you can see we just yield this
value and if we want to we can make this
a little bit a little bit easier to read
so we'll just say from itertools
import count for step in count if step
equals two will actually inject a value
into one of these
TDOT send and we'll send the value 10 in
instead of 1 and then if step equals 5
we'll break out of this ok so here you
can see that's even reactive right we
can send something in it recompute but
it's not lazy yet right and there's a
couple of kind of irritating things that
we have to do with this you'll see the
first few values are not quite correct
now it's not lazy and we want to make it
lace now one problem is unlike Python
functions you know a Python function one
thing you might have noticed is you can
define a Python function like this and
you can throw attributes on it you can't
do that with the Python generator
instance you can't throw attributes on
it so here we'll need to continue to use
a generator formulation but we'll wrap
it in a larger object so what we'll do
is we'll create just a very simple
decorator and we'll call it wrapped and
we'll have a class here called wrapped
and we'll just wrap our generator so we
have a place a storage place to put
something like this
and we'll pump it this is one thing
you'll find with these co-routines you
have to pump them and we don't have time
to talk about this we'll do something
kind of interesting
they'll send ourself into this so we can
do something like this at the top of
each of these generators we can actually
keep track of the state of it itself
okay
and the rest of this is fairly
boilerplate and we won't implement the
entire protocol
okay and we do something like that now
as we do this we can do the following we
can say actually no where did that so
what we can do is the follow here when
we have the terms that we're adding we
might say for each term we can say t dot
subscribers plus equals one and we can
keep track of how many people are
subscribing to these values so we know
if we're dirty or or not and we know how
many people are waiting to see values
from us then what we can do and this
gets really inky but what we can do is
we can say in this new term
and we'll just clip this to zero we can
always every time we yield a value we
can just decrement by one so we're no
longer we're no longer a dirty value and
then what we can do is we'll use our
same trick from before we'll put a
little sleep in there just so that we
can see the dirtiness like take effect
here in the term what we can do is we
can say whenever we compute the term we
can mark ourself as dirty and we can
sleep for some period of time and so
what we'll see is as long as we're not
dirty
it'll just instantly recompute if we're
dirty we this represents a like a small
but very large chunk of a computation
like a deep learning model that's
connected in a graph up to something
else right some learning model that
takes a few seconds to run but only is
run and the graph only recomputes it on
demand as we go up here in the ad it's
not that hard what we have to do we just
have to save if any of our terms are
dirty we just mark ourself as dirty
and we recompute our value so we'll just
freakin will only recompute our value
here but we will compute it once up here
okay so let's see if this thing works
there's gonna be real pain the debug if
it doesn't and then we'll just set
seconds equals to zero so that most of
these are instantaneous and then what
we'll do is we'll actually the one that
we tweaked we'll see
and then functions not iterable oh thank
you and I have to wow you're very you're
really paying attention okay and then we
gotta do one more thing and we yield our
value here and we yield our value there
and
in terms routine terms we have to we
have to decrement this up here
we're also decrement it for dirty here
and let's see if this thing works and
there's one last thing that we're
missing
so I'm not I'm not stupid I did actually
prep a little bit at the set of time
we'll just grab from my preparation yeah
so we'll just grab my prep version here
oh you actually have to use our rapt
class as well let's see if we can
continue let's see if we can continue
with this without screwing this up too
much but if not we'll switch over to the
canonical version but I did I mean I
didn't actually practice this thing I'm
not doing this all on my head okay so
we'll switch over to the canonical
version real quick and we'll just grab
we'll just remove this code here set
paste grab the code from my canonical
version which I promise you I haven't
been cheating the whole time on and move
on and what we can see for this approach
is that
we can pace this okay yeah I know where
that I do know where we're going with
this we'll just grab this code here and
I'll show you this in practice and this
version was the final version that I
wrote in preparing this and I'll show
you the final version because I don't
want you to have to suffer too much of
reading through me live code this it's
gonna be real difficult to debug there
we go
but this is the final version in about
eighty two lines of slightly harder to
write than live coded on stage what we
can see is we can see down here this
generator it'll pause for 10 seconds
when one of the values is updated and
the extra 20 lines of code mean that it
also will I mean it's a graph
computation framework so it'll also
graph the thing so you can see this is
our ad this one's a much harder
computation there's an Ag think it's
another ad we'll close it close it and
you can even see the terms go dirty
though that's like the 9 you can see
that's the one second wait for it to do
the recomputation and it's happening at
each levels and then it should up you
can see that one went dirty and then you
can see each of the results are now
faster again because it's not very
computer and you can see that dirtiness
propagate through the network about a
hundred lines of code using a generator
as you're a fundamental organizing
structure and I'll show you all I added
here was not that much the only thing I
added here was a little bit of an
additional mechanism to use Network X to
draw the thing and you know I guess it's
a little bit easier to do five minutes
before you get on stage than when you're
on stage but for the most part you can
see this code is essentially the same
it's just a generator that yields its
values that waits for it to be signaled
as dirty and then results and you can
see this generator is actually an
interesting structuring mechanism for
larger code by itself it's not
interesting computational mechanism but
what tricks like this you can form
interesting structural things because
each generator by virtue of being a
fixed they a an object that represents a
computation it can also do neat things
like if I had three general
in a sequence I could have them self
elide themselves and infuse into another
one this is the second example I wanted
to do if I happen to be running faster
than I thought I would which is to show
you how you can have a pipeline of three
generators then automatically rearrange
themselves or fuse themselves with
another twenty lines of code and it's
actually not that difficult and you can
see the API here maybe it's a little bit
of a little hinky but it gives rise to
thinking about form formal structures in
their code and I say even though this
API is somewhat hinky a comparable graph
formulation framework that does just
these two pieces there's gonna be at
least two hundred three hundred four
hundred of code with generators and a
little bit of knowledge of how they fit
in to how Python objects work and the
structuring behind them I mean I have 95
lines of code here for a graph
computation framework not too bad and I
almost got it right on the first 5 live
coding it so I hope you enjoyed that
that's more about generators thank you
so much